welcome back to New rockstars and with
King the Conqueror about to arrive in
quantarenia a little bit suspicious that
we haven't seen a lot of Spider-Man the
Multiverse isn't it I mean America
Chavez didn't even know what a
Spider-Man was in most vs Madness what
man Spiderman he has the powers of a
spider hence the name gross
does he look like a spider no no more
like a man climbs wool shoots webs yeah
Bingo out of his butt no oh well maybe I
don't know what if I told you that this
was no accident what if I told you that
there was once a great war between
spider people and the great king the
Conqueror that we might yet see again
this is Rogue Theory the show we pitched
the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love a show made possible
by the support of Norwood VPN more on
those beautiful people in a little bit
but my name is Mt and Gordon Rogue with
me today is the wonderful the amazing
Whitney van laningham what's going on
with me hey hi hello I'm Whitney wow
Wendy wow these are all like things you
would see on a comic book page wow
amazing
and of course our amazing also another
amazing um friend of the show would be
incredible
um host of the film Lost first podcast
it is Eddie Villanueva what's going on
Eddie what's up boom bash Bagel
Biff pow
and my big head gang brother Tommy
bechtold he is also wonderful all
wonderful people what's going on Tommy
hey squelch wet squelch squirmed
squish Splash Splish Splash but yes
um all of my wonderful friends have
assembled here today to talk about a
rogue topic which is what I'm going to
talk about now which is a great spider
war between the spiders and King the
Conqueror because I believe that King
the Conqueror killed all the Spider-Man
before he became he who remains as it
became became
[Music]
the became years yes the BK years I have
a weird reasoning for this because like
we know from Loki that he remains made
the sacred timeline it's like the super
strict ribbon of like this is the
realities that I want to live any other
possibility has been killed so this
implies that before the snake or
timeline was not like this they used to
be branched out used to be fine before
this great war between Kings man and he
remains become as the victor of that war
I have a feeling that the reason why
Peter Parker is the only Spider-Man is
because King the Conqueror killed all
the Spider-Man in the MCU before the MCU
even began I think that he was like all
right you guys are too powerful you guys
are the spider-verse champions you guys
have this great weapon Destiny not in my
Multiverse that's not happening here
maybe in a neighboring Multiverse maybe
in like a Sony Multiverse that's fine
here we don't play that [__] we don't do
that over here so he kills them all and
uh
exactly not my 616. and uh because he's
like you know what Tom Holland has
Zendaya he's gonna be fine he's gonna
have his problems over here so I'm gonna
leave that Tom Holland he's gonna be
fine but all the other Spider-Man they
got they Gotta Die
um so Kane kills them all and I have a
feeling that this will repeat itself in
in the third spider-verse movie beyond
the spiderverse when Kang the Conqueror
visits the spider verse he's like all
right here's a neighboring one
um let's do it again let's kill the
Spider-Man so we can take over these
YouTubers too yeah we're gonna see like
King is going to take over the entire
Marvel multimedia Multiverse um it's
gonna be crazy but what do you guys
think what do you guys think of this
idea of K having killed all the
Spider-Man in the past I I feel like
it's it's it's an obvious thing that we
can say is pretty plausible for the fact
that I feel like one of the biggest
things that people really kind of
Overlook is the events of Juan Division
and the events of Loki and that kind of
Nexus point in the scenes when you know
look uh when King is talking about you
know when oh it just happened and we
have that moment in one division
obviously I feel like in Spider-Man no
way home uh when we have that event
where that large ring is occurring I
feel like that is also happening
simultaneously with the events of those
other two entities day and that is the
reason why maybe all the other
Spider-Man might be gone but I feel like
Andrew Garfield and Toby McGuire are
still going to have a role because they
were actually outside of that event
happening so they're probably the last
three which may culminate in that uh
next spider uh Spider-Man into the
spider-verse uh sequel where we're gonna
have all three of them come together
because everyone else is gone and it's
almost like a almost like a Time Heist
kind of thing
that Kang killed all of the Spider-Man
while our three spider men were doing
the Statue of Liberty Heist yeah dude
that's crazy that's such a wild berry oh
my God
they just happen to be dealing with Tom
Holland's [__] that week so they
didn't get zapped
[Music]
if they're like oh they're trying to to
check other universes and they don't
have any other Spider-Man and they're
trying to figure out what's going on hey
they don't have to worry about casting
anybody or things like I can wait till
the end of the film for all that kind of
stuff but I mean it just it would make
sense that King is going to be one of
the biggest things to hit the MCU thus
far
um his whole role in the entire timeline
of things it puts everything into
question from the very very beginning
all the way up until now so why not have
his impact especially in the series be
as momentous as it was in the series as
it is in other films such as the
Spider-Man film One Division I'm pretty
sure if we do a deep dive I'm pretty
sure we can find other Nexus points if
you will in the timeline referencing
back to that scene in Loki oh yeah dog
that's that's a lot and you know your
kind of spider verse Centric uh Theory I
wonder if we're missing possibly
something in that Madam Webb film that
will be tying Us in because she's a mess
is being right like she kind of sits at
a point where people can cross over
multiverses and like you know some of
the the supposed plot weeks of that film
are that it's like basically a
Terminator uh cover where it's like all
these spider women are coming back to
save Peter Parker from being killed as a
kid before he gets bit that was one of
the theories I don't know if that's
actually going to be true but there are
going to be several spider variants in
that movie right like there's like
several spider women at least so I
wonder if we possibly get a you know a
subversive or a secretive uh Kang Disney
Marvel Sony crossover in that movie or
at least something in a post-credits
scene that opens up the possibility of
can coming in and wiping out spider folk
yeah okay allow it but only if Madame
Webb talks like Arnold Schwarzenegger
that's the only thing like this idea
come with me
that would be I would love that so much
but like no I like this idea so much of
of like Kang potentially factoring into
Madame web that would be a mind-blowing
event but also if you think about it
this is a war right so like Kang is
probably going to hire at the very least
like people to do his War for it like
generals like or like mercenaries in a
way
um and so like we could potentially
seeing him
um like hiring whoever the antagonists
of Madame web is we could be either him
or um whoever that is or like the
inheritors from um despite the original
spider-verse event
um like these vampire type beings
the ultimate Duo that's who I want to
see let's go
with a very distinct mustache
I can't wait for morbius too it's morbin
and Kangen and banging and hanging in
time there you go
back in time morbin back to the future I
don't know I don't know how that works
it is something there's something there
we have the we have the potential we
have the technology the technology yes I
like it like I really like this idea of
like Madame web integrating into the
Multiverse Narrative of the MCU because
we know that like uh Venom is a part of
the MCU now and like I feel like it's
Sony's uh Spider-Man universe or
Spider-Man characters is going to tie
into that as well so yeah I I didn't
even consider that but that makes a lot
of sense considering that Madame web is
a multiversal character and like she is
inherently has to be tied to the The
Narrative especially after
um the way that uh morby ascended with
like the the Multiverse of the no way
home sort of clashing in and bringing in
um Adrian tombs so yeah
on my personal timeline
for me like it is like the implications
of that ending even though like a lot of
people forget about more because they
don't want to talk about morbias for
good reason
um it's just huge it's massive and like
it is that just basically cements Sony
as like part of the MCU fully even
though their movies might not do the
best and like they're sort of tangential
to the MCU narrative
gave us a beautiful gift and yours
Jesus he changed the hierarchy of the
Sony yeah
Johnson could only dream of for DC yeah
are we really surprised it's Jared Leto
I mean Jared Leto could just stand for
about an hour yes
there you go you can't let go of Lego
yeah no I I think that
um like we're gonna see like especially
with Secret Wars on the way there's so
much potential for King to just run
among in the MCU or like in universes
outside the MCU and uh to just bring
everything together I think that secret
Wars is going to bring in literally the
animated Spider-Man I think that we're
going to see miles integrated into that
secret Wars narrative
um because like we know like Marvel and
Sony have the partnership now like they
are like cinematic partners and oh yeah
Sony has been mainly uh getting the
success or like getting the advantage of
that partnership now it's time for
Marvel Studios to be like I want some of
that spider-verse action
animated action yeah we have our own
Animated Universe with what if yeah so
um it's gonna happen it's like it's
gonna happen one of these days so now
let us vote on this crazy Rogue theory
of Kane potentially killing all the
Spider-Man of the past do you guys think
it's rogus bogus or August take it away
yes I think it's fun I think it's good I
think it's morbid time baby
so much to thank Jared Leto for because
of him Kang gets to get with Madame Webb
and then they get to get got all the
Spider-Man and I don't think so I can't
wait for it it's happening I cannot wait
for it I've got to see I've got to see
Yes again yeah my God no I mean I can I
can wait though I can't wait but uh
anyway but yes no
um thank you Whitney I will accept your
rogus with great happiness in my heart
what do you think
um my friend Tommy rogus rogus let's go
double rose what do you think Eddie I
definitely think this is rogus I think
this definitely has potential and to be
honest this is the kind of mindset that
I feel Sony will Clash onto and really
try to integrate themselves in back into
the main point of the MCU especially
utilizing their uh into the spider-verse
uh franchise thus far I mean for all we
know the next into the spider-verse film
that comes out May actually be the
prequel to the premise that you're
talking about and lead into that so that
would be that would be interesting but I
definitely say it's a rogus nice all
right all right thank you triple roll
because I will take this with happiness
thank you guys I love you guys and I do
gotta gotta compliment Eddie once again
on his it happened while they were
fighting on the Statue of Liberty like
while Andrew Garfield was saving Zendaya
that was when King took out all the
other Spider-Man
[Music]
[Laughter]
but up next Tommy's gonna hit us with
his Rogue theory about the Mandalorian
we're going Star Wars y'all but of
course be sure to check out the
roxasbirch.com where you can always find
our latest new rock stars merch from
shirts and hoodies to stickers pins mugs
and so much more and very soon we're
going to have some new merch from the
quantum realm inspired by Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania my goodness look at
Tommy's shirt right now it I love that
design so much it is so freaking cool
I'm so jealous of that shirt I want that
shirt on my body I need it uh the design
is amazing and I can't wait to see you
guys wear it and now show us on the
social media so be on the lookout for
that you can support the channel and
rock some awesome merch by visiting new
rockstarsmerch.com today and we want to
thank our amazing friends over at
nordvpn for sponsoring this video
podcast because you have you ever gotten
extremely hyped to watch a new series or
film only to discover is not available
for streaming in your country it's so
frustrating well nordvpn has you covered
with norvpn you can switch your virtual
location on your device with just one
click giving you the ability to access
streaming services from over 60
countries at no extra cost this opens up
a Quantum realm full of entertaining
content which you wouldn't be able to
access without nordvpn with over 5400
servers in 60 countries nordvpn gives
you access to games and streaming
platforms that currently are not
available in your region and the best
part is nordvpn will not slow down your
online experience at all they've done
the speed test and Norm VPN is the
fastest VPN out there without a question
and they even help keep you safe from
hackers malicious sites and pop-ups
while browsing the internet all with
just one click grab your exclusive of
nor VPN deal by going to nordvpn.com
Rogue Theory you will get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift it's completely risk-free
with the nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee that's nordvpn.com Rogue
Theory and we also want to thank rocket
money for sponsoring this podcast
because do you know how much your
subscriptions cost most Americans think
they spend around 80 a month on
subscriptions when the actual cost is
closer to 200 might be odd where do you
get all this money if you don't know
exactly how much you're spending every
month you need Rock and money rocket
money formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 of people have subscriptions they
forgot about like that streaming service
you bought to watch only that one show
in or that free trial that you've never
even used rocket money will quickly and
easily identify your subscriptions for
you so that you can stop paying for the
ones that you don't want simply find the
subscription that you don't want and
press cancel and rocket bunny will
cancel it for you rocket money makes
cash subscriptions as easy as a click of
a button over 3 million people have used
rocket bunny saving the average person
up to 720 a year so many of us at new
rockstars use rocket money it's helped
us monitor our spending habits and most
importantly cancel those unwanted
subscriptions with no hassle so stop
throwing your money away today cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com Rogue that's
rocketmoney.com rogue rocketmoney.com
rogue and uh for this third ad I would
need my boy Tommy to do this one away
because he's first of all cool cool
stuff empty let's get real it's 2023
it's the new year it's time to make some
resolutions lose some weight hell no
reconnect with my son hell no 2023 is a
year I finally became the proud owner of
a sword where would I purchase this
sword instead I see where do I get this
badass sword from battling Blades of
course battling Blaze designs and sells
high quality swords axes machetes and
connives knives for you simple stuff
there striving to design and create
products with the highest quality metal
bone wood and leather heard of it
leather pretty luxurious guys and it's
more than just blades they sell armor
Shields helmets so you can really get
into character now I've got also got I
call this guy my little dream catcher
right here okay this is the number right
here
look at this okay you can cut a steak I
don't catch a few dreams right now you
can fix a mistake all right battling
blades will take your custom orders look
while you're putting it away Tommy I'm
you're making me very afraid
huh
it's all right be careful please
professional
or not hey battling blades will take
your custom order to make the blade of
your dream seriously check out their
incredible sight it's the everything
they have we've got their high carbon
Damascus steel Bastard Sword in the
office and I'll tell you nobody's a
bigger bastard than me and I feel
incredible so for 20 off you're battling
Blade's order go to battlingblades.com
and enter code Rogue at checkout that's
b a t t l i n g blades.com
b-a-t-t-l-i-n-g battling blades you for
me enter code Rogue checked out to get
20 off your order
I feel safer with Tommy around now I
don't know about you guys but this is
yeah we haven't had an accident in our
office in 15 minutes oh Whitney it's not
it's not from battling blades it's from
my boyfriend's office
that's from battling Brad the battling
blades is better quality than battling
Brett's look at this look at this foam
you couldn't kill a guy with this those
others are challenging Tommy to a sword
fight
Whitney I yield I bet you beat me to
death with foam any day now I've got a
topic here that's gonna blow your socks
off folks Monday night was a very
special night for me okay I just
returned from Las Vegas
and during uh Monday Night Football I
got to watch Tom Brady be humiliated on
National Television but that wasn't the
best part of my Monday night watch your
mouth Tom Brady is a National Treasure
over here Tom Brady is deserves deserves
to get gonorary and burn in hell that's
an old Ace Venture that's today's
scripture reference guys
all right all right now listen to me
what we really got Monday night was the
Mandalorian season three trailer and
everybody was going oh a Droid bar oh
they made a statue for ag-11 oh look at
all those mandalorians no nine yeah the
most exciting part was four Jedi Sabers
drawn staring down a door with a
sparking blade-like object coming
through now I think that color was
purposely left vague and people are
speculating who was behind that door was
it battle droids was it Anakin Skywalker
was it a returning from the dead Mace
Windu no my friends this is who was
behind the door and let me tell you
exactly why none other than Maul
formerly Darth Maul now just mollusion
nasty is behind the door in Mando season
three in the trailer here's why who has
the dark saber at this time Darth Maul
who hates Palpatine at this time Darth
Maul Maul hates Palpatine Palpatine
covets grogu obviously grogu survives
the night of Order 66 because Palpatine
wants his blood now
here's what I think that's Darth Maul
that's Mall sorry I keep calling him
Josh
it's it's the name or no more of the
Star Wars
cuts down the door cuts down the Jedis
takes grogu they escape and for a few
years they have a real Peter Quill yondu
relationship his Maul begrudgingly
carries this little Yoda and an egg
thing around with him kind of confused
as to what to do and how to use its
value and we get a little flashback this
season of maul and Yoda or mall and
grogu so sorry Maul and grogu uh yeah I
don't need I won't take any voting
that's obviously a rogue Assad off the
account so but you guys can
ceremoniously vote if you'd like this is
true
see which other Star Wars characters
Tommy's gonna slightly mix up just a
little bit yeah thank you you know like
when your mom kind of gets like an
actor's name wrong like for example my
mom calls her glenith Paltrow yeah yeah
that's what you're like that but for the
Star Wars Universe
like name name uh confusion it's not
that I don't know their names it's just
when I write them down it makes it worse
if I was just saying them from my head I
would get them right every time then I
look at them and I'm like no no my brain
diffuses to cooperate I don't know
whatever it's been diagnosed many
different what are you talking about I
love oh by way and Canobie yeah you got
my favorite character Darth Vader is my
favorite but I love his son like Sky
mapper let's get it going it's actually
dark Vader next time
is the perfect name all right it really
is vote with your hearts
no I I really like this idea of um Maul
like going after Palpatine because like
you were totally right Maul and
Palpatine are not buddies right now like
they are warring against each other and
like I can totally see while being at
the Jedi Temple and like go after grogu
to get to take it from Palpatine because
I don't know if Palpatine had already
killed
um his brother at this point Savage
um but like
um he's gonna be pissed yeah Palpatine
either way so I would love to see a
series of just Maul and grogu together
and Mom's just like do I kill this thing
do I use it to be my partner and like to
take over the Sith well like that that's
such a good plus it's kind of the
inverse of being jar in it and and grogu
now it's like ginger and it's like the
Happy father Maul is like I don't want
to deal with this freaking thing what a
buddy but but it makes the emperor mad
that I have him well so here's here's
the thing I I actually could see this
being a good rogue rogue idea Rogue
Theory because we we know that Savage
does die during the course of the Clone
Wars uh Series so it is in between
obviously between Revenge of the Sith
and attack of the Clones so we know he
dies uh his brother so in the midst of
all that this would kind of mirror not
only uh Jin and uh grogu but also Darth
Maul and Ezra Bridger in Star Wars
Rebels uh because it could be one of
those situations where Maul didn't
really quite learn how to
be more acclimating to working with kids
with the with the work through and the
time spent with grogu and so he learns
from that and that's why the events in
Rebels occurs and his relationship with
Ezra works out the way it does
um move over to Steve Harrington we've
got a new and expectedly amazing
babysitter
because I could really see this be
something that they throw in there and
because I mean let's be honest Darth
Maul is probably the most badass thing
that's come to Star Wars in a long time
and he's he's it's so unfortunate that
he only lasted one film so they had to
put him in the series and they had to
put him in in two series I wouldn't mind
seeing them uh pop up in this so yeah me
either yeah let's do this so true like I
would love that so much times a million
bajillion that's like literally a
million dollar idea my question is are
they gonna copy the animated series and
do his little crab walking the spider
legs with his little leggings yes oh my
god making him look like that weird baby
from Toy Story yes
that baby grows up to be Darth Maul feel
old yes
if that gets your vote with me then yes
I'm gonna green like that yeah okay then
that gets my vote if we get to see him
do his little spider because it's cool
and bro just like seeing him take people
out where he's just like I only have a
torso do not [__] with me
so fun like oh my God that'd be such a
dope scene of like a picture like a
horror movie scene of him just like in
the darkness just like picking people
off yeah he's so creepy and then that's
how we get Darth Maul into the
spider-verse circle exactly there you go
Darth Maul fights King perfect
so I'm assuming that this guy's Wendy's
vote already yes it's rocus it's roguez
I think it's rogus I would love to see
it happen I would love to see Darth Maul
be more into a lot more of the Star Wars
lore that's being created now instead of
just the one and done from episode one
uh especially in a in a better
live-action version than just what we
saw in Solo so
um I would I would love to see this
rogus bro I think that this is rogus as
hell and like it is so creative that
like I can actually see this being a
thing that will like blow everybody's
minds and like actually like be a great
Avenue for a great spin-off of people
with uh grogu that'd be so dope look at
us rocusing out tonight what a positive
episode
that's a shirt right there Rogan with
the homies oh my God that is a great
shirt
okay vote in the comments below if you
would buy a Rogan with the homies shirt
yes
not to keep pitching a t-shirt that we
haven't sold yet Rogan with the homies
is also a great DND crossover shirt like
I'm really sure
DND show broken with the Hobbies
bro it'd be so much fun I would love to
do something like Harman Quest um anyway
uh but now we are headed into our Rogue
question section of the show you guys
ready for this one yeah because I don't
know if you guys saw this but it is
actually award season I mean everywhere
everything all at once is sweeping the
most wealthy awards at the Golden Globes
the other day and we know some of our
favorite movies of last year often do
get left out of awards season because
you're super super sad and a huge bummer
so what is the roguest award that you
would give to your favorite movie or
performance from last year 2022. uh I
I'm going to give
the movie that I enjoyed the most that
could have just as easily been but
written by an AI that had been fed a
hundred scripts or watched 100 hours of
this guy's acting and that was the movie
Samaritan starring Sylvester Stallone as
oh my God are you serious that Superhero
Movie basically as himself I mean he
just I mean at one point he shoves a
bomb into a guy's stomach and he goes
have a blast
[Music]
I watched it with my nephews and it that
movie is their Godfather now like they
bro sounds like it was made in the 90s
they love it and I give it award most
likely written by a Sylvester Stallone
AI Samaritan
I love that so much Samaritan okay that
is pretty real that is very Rogue so I
like that as a rogue dancer what you got
Eddie so I got two I got um
uh best so the best Bromance borderline
like uh closet you know relationship uh
award goes to RR because yes I was like
you guys just you guys just need to get
together you guys you guys are great
that Bromance is so good that it's like
it's relationshipable and just let's
okay it is I do ship I do ship our for
sure yes I'm gonna piggyback off of his
answer then and say
best moment of multiple animals leaping
out of a single container in one go and
I'm gonna give that award to rrr as well
I don't know it's all good my second one
is uh should have stopped at two Award
with Halloween uh ends or Halloween dies
or whatever that third one was that gets
the should have stopped that two award
because the third one was a little no
bueno that's not no Lord baby that's
like a Razzie that's a Razzie bruh I
mean when you put it on the grand scale
of things I mean just this is an example
being made stop at two if you feel like
yeah
it's uh it's how I feel about uh
negroni's drinks uh that's how I feel
about pieces of pie it's how I feel
about it
uh wives stop it too
[Music]
there we go it's true but no I really
like Tommy's Rogue Samaritan ideas so
ridiculous yeah it was like it came and
went
um Tommy a rogue question winner trophy
for today thank you Jonathan but I loved
all of your suggestions but that is it
for this episode of Rogue Theory thanks
to Our Guest Whitney van letting him
Eddie Villanueva and Tommy Beck told
please follow them on all their social
medias you can support our Channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
over at New rocksearchmark.com you can
follow me at masterton if you want to
see me tweet some weird [__] following
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
YouTube we love you guys so much and
we'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you